[Music]
right before she lost her ability to
speak she was making jokes Olivia
Newton-John's daughter sharing details
about the days leading up to her
mother's death my daughter Chloe is a
very smart and talented young lady I'm
really proud of her Chloe lattanzi
alongside Olivia's husband John
easterling shared their grief on The
Today Show John when do you feel her the
most now late at night
[Music]
early in the morning the interview comes
six months after Olivia died of breast
cancer you you need to decide you're
going to be okay a battle she fought for
decades you just have to go through it
that's the only way you learn Chloe
recalls their final moments together did
she have anything that she wanted to
tell you at the end last word she could
say to me was my sunshine and and and
right before she lost her ability to
speak she was making jokes perfect day
uh I had one today really I got up early
I fed my dog and cat
had a cup of tea get brought one to my
husband had a really nice morning I mean
today was a busy day but just to be at
home with my animals my husband maybe
have Chloe there for visiting
um just hanging out I'm sure there are
beautiful things about everyone loving
her and knowing that everyone missed her
and then how have you been dealing with
that
it actually has been a life raft it has
felt like a big hug from the universe
and I'm very grateful for all of the
people who reached out to us and
extended their heart and their
connection only since I've gotten older
I've been able to really stand back I
look at her and just the Integrity that
she has blows me away I love my mom more
than anything and she's my mama you know
she's she's not Olivia Newton John to me
but I'm so glad that
she was Olivia Newton John for so many
people the last time E.T spoke with
Olivia it was to gush over Chloe
[Music]
something that you recorded during the
pandemic right it is it wasn't really
um interesting thing that happened
because I had not planned on recording
again sometimes
[Music]
I played the song and my husband was
sitting with me and we both became
really emotional because this the lyrics
really hit us it had a beautiful Melody
[Music]
and the first person I thought of was
Chloe to sing it with me because it was
such a personal song and luckily she
agreed because it's not really her genre
of music but um
it was a very special thing to do it
with her I was Honors that you know out
of all the people my mom could have
asked she asked me so that meant the
world to me
[Music]